ضجه كبيره اثارها انتشار فيديو على مواقع
التواصل اجتماعي تظهر من خلاله الفنانه
السوريه اصاله وهي تحمل سيجاره الكترونيه
بيك في كواليس برنامج سعودي ايجل الفيديو
اثر عاصفه من الانتقادات الغاضبه ضد
الفنانه ما دفعها للاعتذار عبر تويتر بعد
تدخل الفنانه احلام للدفاع عنها اصاله
شاركت تغريده احلام وشكرتها
واعتذرت عن تصرفها وقالت الف شكر على
كلامك الطيب شعورك الغالي واليوم كنت راح
ارد واعتذر على تصرف شو طبعا مكان المفروض
اشرف بيك قدام الناس بس كان وقت التصوير
طويل واخذت من صديقه موجوده وشركت منه شوي
للاسف صوروني بتكرر اعتذاري وراح يكون
احرص على صورتي اللي كلنا سوا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الى اي مدى يحق للجمهور نشر خصوصيات
الفنانه الطبيعيه
طيب يعني هاي النقطه خلينا نقولها لطارق
من المنامه يعني طارق وجهه نظر احمد قد
يراها البعض محقه جدا فيما يتعلق انه وين
الخصوصيه في الموضوع هي واريد اصلا في
مكان عام وموجود في برنامج مسابقات بس ليش
اعتذرت لما لما بتعتذر ليس اعتراف ضمني
منها بارتفاع خطا
غالبا يكون مدروس يعني في مشاهير كثار
موجودين حوالين
يحبوني يسوون عشان الاسم ينتشر يعني اليوم
في برنامج همم قوي جدا من العربيه في
الصباح العربيه قال الناقش موضوع اصاله
خلينا نشوف احنا من امس على تويتر وعلى
موقع العربيه طبعا موقع همم كبير انا
اعتمد عليه
نشره الاخبار
والمستقي طبعا كم كم اسم اليوم كم واحد
بحث عن اصاله شيء فاليوم احنا فينا نعرف
حتى في مشاهير يعني حتى صورها يعني نقول
يعني انا انا يعني انا عموما ضد يعني
ما عرضت يعني بس خلينا نقول لحد نصورها
مثلا
الترند اليوم هيحقق الهدف ايجار جديد
الفنان داونز ليصلنا من ناحيه التراندي
الاسم او الترند العمل مثلا او ترن انه
تحديد اتفرج على البرنامج مثلا هذه كلها
اشياء مطبوخه مثلا نقول لها بس انا اشوف
شخصيا ان الانسان ان احنا يعني هي اصاله
ما تعذر ما تعد هي مثال يحتذى به مثل الا
في في الفن في الغناء مثلا
في القطاع الصحي والطبي لكي تلوموها على
ما فعلته يعني لو كانت تدرس اذنهم مثلا هي
اصاله ودخن البيت قدام الناس وهو كل يوم
عم بيطلع بمنتديات ومؤتمرات على مدار
التدخين بنفهم انه هذه فضيحه وهذا لو لكن
عندك شيء اي انسان ممكن يعمله
في ملايين المراهقين بيتابعوها دلوقت اللي
قعدت الدول اللي عم تفرض
على الترحيل عم بتكافح التدخين اغلب الدول
العالم زادت اسعار المنتجات التدخين
والمنتجات بشكل كبير جدا اسالك تتابع او
اي فنان او اي مشهور يتابع من قبل
الملايين المراهقين اللي بيشوفوه بشكل او
باخر يعني في نفس اليوم
تروق اسعار ما بيشربوا بغض النظر يمكن ما
يعجبه
[موسيقى]